good morning believe nation today's
message is put things in perspective
over to you junk load be better when you
have a downtime like if something didn't
hear the way you want what you do to get
back on that positivity I talked to the
mountain I have a mountain next to my
hope that you sold us a delay it goes up
to 2 is like Hello goes up to 2,000 or
2,500 meters oh I talked to the bill DVD
which is a 4,000 meters which is really
further away from my house which I see
every morning I see those two mountain
and I say to these two mountain mountain
I have a problem was when I look at you
you are 37 million old and I'm a little
guy and travel it'll guy will be little
problem can you help me they will pay
come on look what we have already seen
so many years no problem is the lamb no
problem come on get up just get up
that's it entrepreneurs do stupid things
when they lose perspective people do
stupid thing is when it looks respective
you make decisions that are not in the
best interest of your long-term self of
the best version of yourself because
you're so clouded by what's happening in
the moment and you can't step out above
I mean via I may be the wrong target for
this one I have a hard time with this
message mostly because I don't get lost
that much in the day-to-day I don't lose
perspective that much i think it's just
more my personality i don't get to highs
with the highs and they don't get to
lowes with the lows I'm always
constantly on extreme like here's what
we're trying to do okay this is the
problem great let's problem solve it but
a problem my business doesn't have a
major impact for the most part on how I
feel about myself and so we can get back
on it there's been maybe five days in my
life where I've just been so
or out or crazy that lost perspective on
what I was trying to do I think about
when you know the hardest day of my life
when I told my business partners that I
quit and it was just kind of in the
moment frustrated feeling out of control
feeling like I had no value to give
feeling so worthless that I made a rash
decision telling him that I quit and it
didn't have the perspective when I got
up the next day and I went back to work
I just realized I had to find a
different way to say i realize just
still something that I really cared
about and so I don't really do a lot of
things where I lose perspective but I
can understand for others how it can be
I'm the weird one I'm the I'm the crazy
one I really does not most people I
think one thing though that that can
definitely help is gratitude I think
when you are grateful for the things in
your life you easily gain more
perspective it's something that I have a
daily routine of and have had for years
because it also just makes me feel good
if you think about how fortunate you are
even just be watching this video to have
internet to have a house you know to be
fed to live in an age where you have
access to people who've done things that
you want to do and can learn from where
ten years ago even just didn't exist
forget about your what your grandparents
or great-grandparents had access to for
the air that you get to breathe you know
for the people in your life for you just
being a human being instead of an ant
you know like there's so many things you
can be grateful for and just thinking
about those things can make your
problems seem a lot smaller a lot less
significant a lot less important and
that will allow you to then go up and do
the right thing so I'd encourage you
that if you ever feel like life is
spiraling out of control one try not to
make any decision when that's happening
trying to make an important life
decision by reacting quickly to
something just hold your tongue and
sleep on it and then to just try to
think about what you can be grateful for
what is good in your life there may be a
lot that you feel is terrible in your
life but compared to most of the world
you've got it pretty good and it's
really hard to be depressed and angry
and vengeful and hateful
spiteful it's hard to hold those
emotions at the same time as being
grateful and so if you can focus on your
gratitude and what you really are
thankful for they can help give you the
perspective you need to make the best
decision for you so the question they
today is this is what I do every day I'm
curious three things that you are
grateful for leave it down the comments
below super curious to find out and we
will join in the discussion I also want
to give a quick shout to Christian
Christian thank you so much for picking
up a cup of my book your one word it
really really really really means a lot
to me and I hope you're enjoying it
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is and i'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot i
benchpress a believe nations thank you
so much for watching if you want to
learn more about this subject get a
little bit deeper on it i'm going to
share some extra bonus clips that i hope
you'll enjoy my question I'm entropy 93
grain but not all day are great in a
combined ohio infantry for tap day I
think there's massive confusion around
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship sucks
I mean it's lonely it's high-risk I mean
I can't live without it but it's like a
bad boyfriend right a girlfriend right
like like if there's a ton of bad days
being an entrepreneur not to mention
ninety-eight percent of entrepreneurial
ventures are going to fail so there's
gonna be a really bad day in your future
you know hopefully not for you I'm
plenty you know for me I don't you know
I think it's a very personal question I
think it's how you're wired I'm so all
in entrepreneur I prefer the pain I
think one of the reasons I love the jet
so much is because they bring me so much
pain you know I i love the climb to me
the setback is exciting i love when
something goes wrong it's where I shine
the most but that's not for everybody
right I mean it can be very difficult
and when you start affecting your life
and your loved ones and all the other
things if you get real nasty to me the
way I handle things even is a few rare
days when I really strut
so I take a real step back and make
pretend that somebody called me and told
me that my mother or daughter were
killed and I know that's very dark and I
apologize but it's really what I do I
literally am able to at my deepest most
struggling moment within business take a
step back and remind myself that I could
make a trillion dollars tomorrow on
Bitcoin and and if something bad
happened to the people I love the most
that it would mean nothing and it very
consistently rewires me very quickly I
just put business in perspective at the
end of the day you know it's money for
me it's not really money it's my legacy
so I get hurt by it a little bit more
but uh yeah I mean if you know I put in
perspective it's money and you know what
up until I had a daughter even while I
was married uppal to when I have Nisha
four years ago I secretly wanted to lose
all my money I had this weird twisted
dark fantasy of losing everything just
to rise again like a phoenix and remind
you I mean obviously you can't come on
show like this without mention of the
wanking in the toilet thing what we try
to visit in the store today which one he
arrested oh that's cool that's that one
yes the one that worried about time I
got caught you bet that was
[Applause]
six is it may be the way you talk about
it you're fantastic sort of unapologetic
versus then you didn't go into hiding
you didn't you know sort of go you know
draw the curtains like that was it the
next night you were out in a restaurant
in LA having dinner Lulu well I mean I
what's to apologize for you know I'm a
gay man i'm at the time I was like 36
years old can I be if I'm perfectly
honest I'm perfectly perfectly honest
outside of my career I've had a terrible
run of luck that started about 10 years
ago I've I've I've watched a partner
died I've watched my mother die I went
just after that I had I went to see a
back surgeon who told me that if I
didn't have two votes were removed
within the next six months to a year
that I could paralyzed so you just
learned how two different perspective I
don't give a toss if people have a real
problem with me you know having
I'm a different perspective on life I
lost a lot of great things but I still
have a lot of incredible things and the
press doesn't really enter into it do
you feel underrated as a reference not
as of lately like which is crazy for a
long time and for years I was pissed so
a song on the album called buried alive
is musings about that exactly you know
it's about like me kind of going how
come he gets to so and so cosine or how
come he gets that or how come they get
that I can tour the world i can sell out
shows i got fans i got just what the man
like being angry you know i had a friend
tell me she basically said those same
people who have the cosines and have the
list and have the looks are the same
people are going how come I got fans
like this then how come I can't sir
we're on my own how come I can't just
like what the [ __ ] kind of put things in
perspective for me and let me go okay I
don't have it yet but if i keep fighting
i keep working hard and i keep staying
on this path it's going to happen you
know and as of late within the last few
months man just from you know like
releasing the singles and the music
videos and like this solid body of work
i truly began to get laughs deserve